many many many of the mental health
issues that we see nowadays in young
people and in adults is the consequence
of disrupted circadian rhythms because
of a lot of time in a two-dimensional
screen space which I'm not condemning I
spend time on and put out most of my
content on social media and in addition
to that the lights are too bright at
night and they not getting enough
sunlight during the day an important
thing to understand about our ciran
system and health is that in the morning
and throughout the day your eyes are
less sensitive to light and you need
more of it in order to get what you need
and at night your eyes are far more
sensitive to artificial lighting and you
need far less of it in order to disrupt
your circadian system in bad ways
disrupt your mental health now does that
mean you have to walk around with
sunglasses at night and Dim All the
Lights in your house well no but you
could afford to dim them a little bit
you could afford to switch to the red
light function on your phone it's
amazing when you start to think about
how most people exist now it's too dim
not enough light for them during the day
especially not enough sunlight and then
it's too bright for them at night